[Musik]
mit ingres kurz ich muss im jahr
die diplomatie gewisse dinge beibringen
habe ich ihm gesagt hast du das tust du
wenn du wenn du wenn du bist für die
leute nach hause gehen dass wir nur mehr
wasser zum trinken angeboten
aber es ist nicht nicht die gespräche
zum abschluss gebracht respekt wenn sie
diese zeichen und verabschieden sie sich
gäste die überlangen bleiben werde
nirgends geschätzt
[Musik]
zettel auf deutscher wie allah
diplomatie ist in der schweiz nicht
besonders beliebt man kennt böse wenn
das ich glaube ich schon
[Musik]
auf sie zählen wir für die nächste
jahrzehnt
[Musik]
kairo wieder los mit der
diplomatenausbildung fast sechs monate
nach der geburt ihrer tochter eine pause
gemacht
gespannt darf botschaft
[Musik]
da die stellvertretende missionschefin
muss samir überzüge wenn sie den gang
hoch diplomatique erfolgreich
abschließen konnte und dass man
persönliche kontakte nicht wirklich
entscheiden und vieles gab mündlich und
wirklich über verpackung macht mit
direkt oder als unterstützer vermuten
daher oder sowohl organisieren als klar
welches meistens übernachten offizielle
arbeitszeit verbringt noch expliziter
haben für ihre ordnung nach athen oder
ort durfte hosek unterhaltungsportal
thaksin relativ lang
[Musik]
morgen früher in mir mal der alles
andere schweizer diplomat ausbildung
erzogen und lebt inzwischen chance
ganzes jahr
die lebensrhythmus hydra post
na ja das problem ist dem tennisplatz
das mit flutlicht hand das heißt am
anblick ist relativ schwierig zu spielen
wenn ein halbes hundert grad und
tagsüber ist das mega heiß zwischen
dresden feucht ist gerade so gut dass
sie mit der lokale handspiele und im
vergleich zu der schweiz soll da viel
viel günstiger brauche eine salbe über
attraktionen
[Musik]
am alexander sehen die freundin simone
extravagante zog
[Musik]
die beide im ausland kann erklärt und
damit sie an gott in myanmar
und hoffen
hockey awards for free
[Musik]
myanmar ist bis vor kurzem neue
militärdiktatur für die meisten leute
ist eine große gefahr mit mir persönlich
zweite aber sich in der öffentlichkeit
auszudrucken
das ist schwierig das hat dort viele nur
respekt davor dass der staat wird unter
dem klang des landes aber insbesondere
für ihre eigene ruf und das saarland
gewarnt mit ihnen zu schaffen
menschenrechts aktivisten sprechen von
einem schleichenden völkermord den burma
an den muslimischen rohingya im land
begeht aber auch angst
sie wird von den uno experten kritisiert
die de facto regierungschefin habe ihre
position nicht genutzt um die
gräueltaten zu verhindern
auch buddhistische mönche heizen den
hass gegen muslime im land an besonders
mächtig ist die bewegung avatar
alexander muss über die bewegungen
politische beschrieben
er trifft den bekannten einheimischen
politologe
die buddhistische nationalismus wird
also hoch verbauten nicht genug gemacht
sein kontakt entspannen die schätzung
für alexander und vielleicht wichtig für
die schweiz
sie bricht auswirkung auf die politische
beziehungen zwischen der schweiz und
myanmar
mit dem politischen geschrieben ist das
wirklich ein meilenstein
wo man wo man noch mal das ganze familie
jetzt und anhand von dem neuen
aktivitäten
[Musik]
die international corporation
der auris von ganze
[Musik]
das interessanteste thema vermisst und
roxy sie mit 2x also jetzt für mich
alles sehr streng sich am ersten tag weg
[Musik]
gebracht wird
man kann fast
senegal
die sehne diplomat uns bild weniger
erlaubt ist frau mit dem thema was tun
was zwischen schwerpunkt der schweizer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
es gibt länder die waffe haben und es
gibt länder die wasser brauchen für
diese spannungen auf der welt aber hier
in westafrika wenn wir ein beispiel von
länder die sich gut verstanden haben und
wo die eine intelligente teilung von von
wasserressourcen zu stabilität wird und
die idee der schweiz war einfach zu
sagen hey wollen wir da nicht einmal
diese leute von zentralasien nach
westafrika bringen so dass die mit denen
diskutieren können da hinstellen
vielleicht vielleicht nicht gute lösung
um opportunitäten
die schweiz erhält eine sehr positive
visibilität in diese ganze konstellation
ohne zu viel zu machen einfach als
vermittler
[Musik]
das nicht blauäugig wenn man
menschenrechte frieden und gleichgewicht
auf der welt und umwelt verteidigen dass
ich im interesse vor allem dem land
natürlich hätte man eine humanistische
komponente ob extrem wichtig ist und wo
mir frohsinn und stolz sind dass die
jungen sich dafür einsetzen und das ist
immer da aber es geht auch um
interessensvertretung von irland wo es
interesse hätte das welt friedlich
umweltfreundlich gut organisiert und
demokratisch ist der shop dies
tischmitte botschafterin unterwegs
sie endet es wichtig strafe zum thema
wasser
lautrec
weg sind habe ich erfahren dass jetzt
auch noch nachschauen dass da jemand
nicht kommt dann wäre dann bei mir zu
hause ankommen ist das das erste was wir
tun werden
die tischordnung rangieren ja ich darf
ich habe mich schon schauen wie du das
machst das ist wirklich etwas
da habe ich null angefangen die streams
tag ja ja klar
dann möchte ich dir im top line geben
und wenn dann die geister kommen
das tut den gästen sagst ja bitte frau
ganze aussieht das ist ihr platz dass du
sie an den platz leitet residenz vor der
schweizer botschaft
21 bars der schweiz sind extra angereist
cross spezialist aus der schweizer
experte im senegal kräne lehre kommt
ganz offensichtlich direkt vom spuren
[Gelächter]
gut jetzt möchte ich dich peter walter
und und hat es wieder nicht weil ich
weiß dass ist genau um vier
das macht sich jetzt am tisch ordnung
[Musik]
der stick aus schotter habe sie sagen
also alles wartet wichtige themen
besprochen
der sport ist reagiert sofort gekommen
wie nie
es geht in bonn cisco warmen applaus
[Musik]
teams nord wird wieder geschafft versuch
von drei aus der schweiz wichtige bild
von seiner kauf eines projekts schweiz
will das asiatischen staaten verweist
auf eine karte und lehre wir mit der
knappen ressource wasser umgeht damit
drei konflikten stellt
messi
[Musik]
wenn alle
schweizer botschaft kleine konzert vom
schweizer musikrat worden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
beckett oder leben und sich sehr
spannend
das bild vermittelt einfach und
kommuniziert aber im land wichtig sie
[Musik]
gabriel es die botschaften von roth
besonders job extrem wichtig ich habe
sehr gerne mache und wie das ist wichtig
dass man ja dass man im express
aber das ist schon gesagt dass mit
entwickler in zukunft auf job-sharing
machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der lex andere politisch spricht über
die aktuelle situation in mir mal fertig
da gerade noch auf zentrale meter bahn
es sind die beine ganz feuchte ab das
sei gut so was muss ein kondensiert sie
und das ist auch der anspruch ist vom
neuen départements vorstellen das reh
kompakte wird das muss versuch möglichst
wenig salzwasser das kurz stören die zu
über nicht weil im moment ist erleben so
weit fertig aber ich mich nicht es
natürlich wirklich wunder was du dazu
denke es muss eine aussage haben es muss
starke analytische elemente haben der
wichtige teil am ende der sich
unterscheidet auch von einer rein
akademischen kurz papier etwas das
wirklich für die schweizer politik
bedeutet
alexander lang oder politische break
schaffen da mozilla die arbeit darüber
entscheidet
im jargon wohnte mit seiner freundin
simone vier zimmer wohnung job für die
studierte soziologin
[Musik]
was gemacht wird relativ schnell
betätigung von bmw shop hat
und das hat ja wirklich
wenn der alexander diplomaten und billig
besteht kurz zusammenarbeit aus der alle
vier jahre ins land hund und schafe
[Musik]
über
new york
[Musik]
es ist gut wenn die nachmittag handy und
dadurch mehr so gut oder das buch lesen
und dass das buch ich glaube ich sonst
auch louis c
es lebe der diplomatie hanna einsam sie
sieht anderthalb jahre ist christina
dante aber drin für ihre
zwillingsschwester gesetze nicht richtig
[Musik]
gemacht
ok kloos sprach ich recht blutig die
anderen diskutiert ob sie das betreten
[Musik]
naja ich bin schon macht dick
leoni war einfach so dass ich heute
nicht warum ich so stand's mit ihr
telefonieren
[Musik]
die show baptist schafft immer wieder
raum buchen hat einmal free hat sowie
hütter sich für die ganze woche vor
das ist ein supertag
doch die beste kuss kuss kurz vor seiner
ansicht des shops ist und seine
partnerin trend social vorfall auf sich
allein gestellt sie
[Musik]
was mir viel geholfen hat nicht heim zu
führen oder wohlzufühlen ist eigentlich
die ist eigentlich die arbeit
die arbeit ist ein großes
integrationsfaktor du bist da führt ja
weit und dann findest du sehr schnell
eigentlich deine familie so die kollegen
und köln an der botschafter von einander
der wirtschaft und so das hilft
eigentlich
[Musik]
ich weiß dass wenn ich in einer
beziehung sein möchte dass für das 1 1 1
1 1 riesigem thema sein weil dein job
bestimmt die geografisch für die andere
person
ja es hat mich eines handlichen war
traurig das zu sagen aber ich möchte ich
verteile single zu sein und das ist das
ist ja das ist so
[Musik]
das heißt obwohl es darf dabei aber ich
hätte wahrscheinlich zu hause für jonas
und kathrin ist ein wichtiger tag
kathrin das konzert am festival musiker
aus bringt sie noch ihren ford zum
konzert von buenos aires stattfindet
klinisches nicht einfacher das eigene
berufsleben zurück zu stellen
umso wichtiger dass sie wieder weg auf
die bühne wollte das immer also das ist
mein traum dabei zu sein
mit etwas was ich wirklich liebe
vielleicht noch kurz nach damit er
wirklich alles hast eine schuhe mein
kleid waren die cds eine banane habe ich
auch okay
jonas will es kompliziert
alles okay okay und wie sieht es aus ja
also ansehen und sie ist noch nicht
abgefahren
vom treffpunkt geworden sei dass der
fahrer für kathrin ist nico schrum
zuletzt jonas sie springe eigentlich gut
gut dann gehen wir direkt problem jetzt
gelöst
ja ok ich muss da kurze ausfahrt einen
moment
[Musik]
und ja was möchtest du was wir jetzt
machen
ich komme sich mal abwarten
[Musik]
wo bist du jetzt
dann gehen wir jetzt auch
ja es ist wahr dass jetzt ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der alexander und feedback was sie
politisch spricht über hallo ich habe
den wenig gelesen also ich finde ich bin
wirklich wirklich sehr gut das ist es
ist alles drehen das ist ja informativ
und das ist schildert wirklich gut das
ganze das ganze thema allgemein ist ja
ein bisschen noch zu lang
die zusammenfassung am anfang ist auch
ein bisschen ein bisschen zu
detaillierten das bild vom schlafenden
riesen dass du auch schon auch als als
titel genommen hast
ich habe mich gefragt ist das wirklich
ein schlafender riese avatar ist
eigentlich und da der oberfläche sehr
aktiv vielleicht ist das auch eine
sprache sache ich weiß nicht aber du
hast recht ich also ich habe mir das
eigentlich auch zweimal über leid
überlegten sie mit diesem titel und wie
es genau zu schildern soll
aber es ist ja es macht definitiv sind
dann das noch ein bisschen zu
präzisieren
ja das hat ich glaub ich glaube das ist
das ist schon ein perfekter vielen dank
für das bietet mehr glücklich sind und
das sind alles fragen die ich mir auch
im prozess vielleicht ein bisschen
selber gestellt habe soll ich da ein
bisschen mehr oder dort ein bisschen
mehr super danke für die vielen dank
hast du da gemacht wieder
nein ich versichere spanisch für
alexander wichtig so bricht muss
natürlich bald nur mehr schreibe ich
glaube nur kurz und bündig jetzt muss
nachdem literarisches kunstwerk sondern
das sind die informationen wo man
vermittelt und das gab es noch nie vier
einfache bei mir
das ist definitiv das privileg sie da
der 15 männer können verbringen
also ist es enorm spannendes landes
komplett jetzt land es ist nicht einfach
zu gestalten dass berichte noch für
lange zeit als 1500 zum möglichen
general und trompeters enorm
faszinierend
der jonas forscher hat kathrin chablis
ihren auftritt
[Musik]
kathrin spielt sich noch so kalt
so kalt ich bin meine hände nicht
wirklich
[Musik]
es ist so kalt ist jeffrey ja das ist
eigentlich auch im zeichen von
nervosität aber mir ist jetzt auch
wirklich kalt dass meine nase ist kalt
und genau eigentlich für mich mal meine
hände hier am nacken
[Musik]
doch sie war marty
das ist eine jacke würde ich jetzt auch
gerade haben müsste ich geb nein ich
meine mich immer ist sie noch ein
bisschen lustiger abend nicht gut wenn
ich und jetzt waren und dann für mich in
dieses loch rutschen kinder schon ich
will jetzt einfach frierend durch ok
das konzert ist nur für katrin sondern
auch für region aus wichtig für mich
wichtig dass jeder und jede faser die
lgt liter schafft hätte und patina es
ist dass die klassische gitarre
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gc
was mich aber immer noch überall so wie
meine diplomatie tätig und kathrin für
folgte wieder schaffte der musik was sie
denkt dass der andere orte klappt
ja ja einen gefallen sie hatten alle
hundertmal gesagt wie gut dass sie ihnen
gefallen hat
die große abschlussprüfung für jonas in
der nächsten folge wurde unit diplomaten